well do you have a question for me how
can i help you so
here i am you know my one of my favorite
my favorite comedian i will say oh thank
you
i didn't like you know what i i got
really nervous when you said one of i
just go down a spiral
so thank you for just knocking me up to
like i'm sure that's
if even that's not true just stick with
what you've said i like it so i'm just
gonna go with it
hey number one uh so uh if i could ask
you
anything i would ask uh if you could
fight
a serial mascot like a mascot uh that is
on cereal
what who do you think you could take in
a fight
like who do you think you could beat up
yeah great question
that's a great question i'll start let's
think it over captain crunch is an old
man yeah yeah and yeah clearly passed
his prime
yeah and uh i'd like to think that i
could take
you know like the tricks bunny he's got
a long reach
yeah long reach he's got a lot of energy
i think it would be hard to connect
uh but captain crunch i was gonna say
you couldn't touch what did you say
tony the tiger like you would not be
able to get anywhere tony the tiger
would
rip me a new [ __ ] instantly you know
his rip
he'd instantly grab my ass and tear open
my [ __ ]
and then he'd say it's great you know
um so no i don't want to i don't want
anything to do with tony the tiger
uh i think that you can the froot loops
toucan is an endangered
species don't you think you should fight
the lucky charms guy as a kind of mono
amano
oh two oh i get it two leprechauns going
at each other man is that what you're
saying
kinda yeah you're related i do have to
say the lucky the luck
you have to refuse yourself he's my
third cousin
the lucky charms leprechaun um i
do think the leprechaun has dragged my
people back
like three centuries with his antics and
behavior yeah
so he has it coming but i worry i think
he has magical powers
and i know the irish they'll do anything
he's probably got a knife in his boot
he's gonna stick it in my rib i'm going
for captain crunch
again an elderly man passed his prime
you know he says he's a captain but we
don't really see any evidence of that
oh he has a ship i mean he theoretically
has an armada he could launch
his navy no we haven't seen the ship in
a long time okay
and he talks a lot about how he's a
captain and then you look at that
uniform
you know what i mean he looks like tito
jackson it doesn't look like a real
captain's uniform you know so
i'm gonna go after captain crunch and
that's gonna be a very short fight i'm
gonna just
i'm gonna crush his face i'm gonna i'm
gonna take i'm gonna
peel that mustache off his face and i'm
gonna watch him eat it
we're gonna wear that as an epaulette
like he has epilepsy
i will put the mustache on my shoulder
like one of his little epaulettes and
i'll say no i'm the captain
um yeah that's my plan maggie you seem
like you've thought about this have you
have you figured out who you would fight
yeah who maggie who do you want to fight
uh see i would i'm glad i feel like we
agree i was thinking captain crunch
because yeah he seems like a senile old
man he
found his outfit like you know in a
drawer somewhere and he's like ah this
is my persona now
i don't think he's a real captain and uh
you know you're fantastic maggie you're
fantastic i
i i wish i could go on a road trip with
you for like six weeks because i think
we would never
we could exhaust this topic alone we
could talk for like this would
get us like 8 000 miles this one topic
because you're absolutely right
the captain he's overstayed his welcome
he really has
you know it's it's time he retired and
whoever lieutenant crunch is moved up
don't you think 100 you know it's like
it's like remember last year
when they killed off like mr peanut and
then i had like baby peanut
i feel like you know this you know
there's gotta be a baby crunch or
something you know
he can grow up become earned his ranks
or something he's gotta
he's gotta earn it are you calling for a
crunch mutiny
let's go i'm totally foreign and you
know what captain crunch seems way too
uh comfortable he's not on his toes you
know what i mean
uh and i think this captain crunch
mutiny could happen very quickly
and he would be dispatched immediately
and then we would control
you know because also i think he went a
little nuts i mean it started as captain
crunch then they added crunch berries
then it became peanut butter crunch then
they said there's a there's a captain
crunch cereal that's only crunch berries
it's called
oops all berries he made a mistake yes
he hasn't been there now if that's not a
senile old man
i don't know if anything should qualify
him for
uh you know immediate ejection from the
navy
it's the creation of of an all oops all
berry crunch that's a clear mess up i
know i think you should be awarded the
nobel prize for that that's the best
cereal ever made
yeah have you had it yeah yeah you know
what's actually pretty good is peanut
butter crunch
oh yeah have you had that yeah what's
happening yeah
it's really changing your mind about
everything yeah you're changing my mind
now it's such a good cereal
let's go after those flintstones on
fruity pebbles true story my my
wife is a health nut and she's always
having the kids you know
have plenty of spinach and eat really
healthy food and oatmeals and fruit
and i finally just said this is
ridiculous i want these kids to
understand what it's really like to be a
kid
so i went not to the organic market but
to a real supermarket
and i bought captain crunch froot loops
and sugar pops
and i think apple jacks and i brought
them back to the house and i
hid them and then at the appropriate
time i brought them out in front of my
wife and i said
it's time that my son became a man
and yes and i introduced him to these
cereals
and uh i haven't done it since but
uh he really was like wow this is
incredible and we sat there the way
people do
our backs hunched yeah what you do is
you put the cereal in the bowl you pour
in the milk you eat it
no one speaks no it's just munching okay
then you get to the bottom and there's a
little bit of milk
and rather than drain that milk you add
more cereal
and fill it up again and then add more
milk and we just
plow ahead and it's joyless we look like
those old ladies at the slot machines
that are just feeding quarters in
that's what we were doing we were just
chowing down cereal
he was high on sugar for like six days
my wife was not
amused but i thought this he needs to
know he
needs to know don't you think maggie
yeah oh 100 that's a that's a rite of
passage
yes yeah this will put hair on your
chest i said
i think i did the right thing